we also have two stories which are
component of this and that was the
transgender models that were placed on
the swimsuit ads the debate here is uh
you want to pull pull these up so we
have you have Kim petris this is a
biological male and then you have this
individual Elena Bloom also a biological
male and these are the uh this was
swimsuit 2021 and swimsuit 2023 someone
tweeted uh some journalist said they did
not get woke and go broke they were
going broke and tried to get woke as a
means to save themselves
which I find very funny the argument
then becomes your company is going under
you know that dudes like looking at
pictures of like scantily clad women so
you decide to put males on your cover
that's like a like look the the the the
Sports Illustrated swimsuit model
Edition was always to get dudes all
excited hot and bothered so they buy the
magazine whatever or read the magazine
putting dudes on it like biological
males that look like women that have
like gotten Sur surgery and hormones
that probably pissed off a lot of guys
like look if look if you're trans you do
your trans thing you be you go go live
your life but I got to tell you it is
trans people have made the argument it
is dangerous for them if they go out to
a bar and a guy is like hitting on them
and then finds out they're actually
trans it's dangerous that people can get
violent what do you what do you think
Sports Illustrated when all of these
dudes are like yeah I'm going to pick up
this there's like some chick on the
cover and they like wait a minute what
the they're going to get mad about it in
the same way like that is a commonly
held belief among trans people why would
Sports illustrate like perhaps the
company's going under but all they did
was was accelerate their decline yeah I
don't I don't understand that whole
thing about trying to appeal to like
that audience or whatever when it's a
fraction of you know the general
population and obviously you know not
their base same thing with like budlight
or like Harley Davidson or all of these
other people um like it's just a
fraction of the overall audience not
only their a audience so but but I I
think if you break it down it all comes
down to AI will replace all media yeah
seriously why why would any dude buy a
buy a magazine or go to Sports
Illustrated to look at a woman in a
bikini right this is the issue so
they're like we'll try anything and
they're hoping that woke activists will
pretend to like it in reality all the
dudes who used to buy Sports Illustrated
or the Victor or or pick up a Victoria
Secret catalog for for for doing Dirty
Deeds let go on the internet now dude
I'm looking at sport who owns Sports
Illustrated it's company called
authentic Brands group who so generic
who owns authentic Brands group well
there's two two companies this some
investment Capital firms own them CVC
Capital partners and HPS Investment
Partners own authentic Brands group this
company has been turned into a skin suit
by people with global agendas this they
they care nothing about the survival of
Sports Illustrated they bought it and
they've they've turned it into something
that it wasn't I don't know who who they
are exactly but the headquarters is in
Luxembourg uh of CVC capital and the
headquarters of HPS that could be
anybody is in New York city so that's a
it's both a luxemborg
Bourgeois how do you say that burish
luxembourgish company and an American
company co-own the company that owns
Sports
Illustrated yeah and that could liter be
anybody could be anybody dude yeah what
company the company that owns Sports
illustrat the company that owns Sports
illustrator is called authentic Brands
group and then the company that owns
that there's two investment Capital
firms that own authentic Brands group I
mean at the end of the day I think
everything is is owned by or every every
large company is is owned by an
investment Capital you know um they I
mean yeah like even like conquered music
group The the last label that I was on
they're owned by an investment Capital
company group or whatever I think we're
we're we're already people don't
understand this too we're AI music is
already here oh oh yeah as as a as an
aside Sports illustrator got bought by
this authentic Brands group in 2019 so I
wouldn't be shocked if that's when their
downfall be became you know would be
cool if like it was 10 years ago
somebody at Google he's like working on
his computer and then he's like all
right that's the final line of code if I
press enter I'll have created a very
rudimentary artificial intelligence he
presses enter and then that is the
singularity point where the AI turns on
and then just starts reading the
internet compiling data getting smarter
and smarter exponentially now now we're
at the point where we are totally
oblivious to the fact that there is a
sensient omnicient AI machine buying up
everything and everything that's
happening with the collapse of these
institutions and wokeness is an AI
entity like manipulating stock market
stealing value gaining control and
eventually we're going to be like who
owns anything it's this weird company
called you know senent omnicient Inc
what is this and then you know turns out
one AI just bought and owns everything
it does annoy me when you see who owns
that company and then it's another
company and you're like well who owns
that other company and it's the company
that they own you're like what okay by
Design I think I reach the top when I
see that black rock owns Vanguard and
vangard owns Black Rock portions of it
they own portions of each other so crazy
well I mean like they do own portions of
each other sure and that's that's fair
but like the thing the people that own
Black Rock and it's like there are big
you know big uh big time owners there
trillionair people that own I don't know
if they're TR apparently there are
trillionaires the people the people that
own like the majority Shares are big but
the rest of that is like everybody else
in America because like all the 401ks
and everyone's retirements and
everyone's you know Investments and
stuff all that stuff is mixed up in in
Black Rock and and uh you know what
Vanguard stuff like that State Street
those are State yeah so it's like yes it
is true that there's big money in those
corporations and and in those uh
investment firms and stuff but it's also
like Grandma and and moms you know her
the the the fixed income that she's on
it's like that stuff's all invested
there too so it's I just it's people get
so wrapped up in the in the bagging on
obviously bad things that they do they
forget that there are good they they
start bagging on capitalism as a
concept when they do that and I think
that yeah corporate corporatism is a
whole other Beast I don't think these
corporations should have should have the
rights of people I don't know when what
the I mean guess I see it from the
businessman's perspective and the
businessmen are the ones that are
writing the laws so I see why they did
that for themselves I don't like that
though well what are you thinking isn't
it to like prosecute to help them hold
them accountable I don't remember exact
I don't why they got personhood I don't
know the actual what just legally I
think it's just legally the thought
process behind it is they're the
corporations are made of people they're
culpable and they're made of people you
know it's like they're they're the
people the corporation isn't an entity
that is removed from the people that uh
that yeah you know make it this is it
says corporate personhood uh or Jurish
jial P personality is the legal notion
that a a jial person such as a
corporation separately from its
Associated human beings like owners
managers or employees has at least some
of the legal rights and responsibilities
enjoyed by natural persons in most
companies a corporation has the same
rights as a natural person to hold
property enter into contracts and to Su
or be sued yeah corporations owning
property that's a bit of a uh an issue
we're looking at cuz Black Rock buying
up a bunch of land try and make people
Perpetual renters but Tim ow owns this
house and this is and like or Tim's
corporation owns this house and it's and
and stuff so it's like that's actually
not true small corporations maybe okay I
don't know I don't know how your
business is struct is structured I don't
know I I speaking I'm speaking out of
turn but it is it is very normal for
like a corporation like you know like
Herz rental cars own owns cars like why
like the people that owns let me let me
tell you the nightmare scenario that we
are entering okay I'm hanging out there
the local casino several months ago or
or last year and I have an issue so I
say I'd like to speak with you know the
manager you know I I I put on my Caren
wig and I said I want to talk to the
manager and they said there isn't one
that was it I'm not kidding modern large
corporations like casinos don't have
managers they do to a certain degree but
what ends up happening is they say okay
I have a issue and a security guy shows
up and says I'm here and I'm in charge
of security I say who's the boss who's
the guy who like is in charge of the
casino that I could talk to about my
problem they go there isn't one there
are small managers for each individual
area I ended up getting help because one
of the guys who handles the food for the
casino is a fan of the show and I ended
up meeting him and he says I'll reach
out to someone and then someone else
there was no boss you know I noticed
that but but but so we've it's it's not
just this one Casino thing that's
happened there have been many instances
where I've gone to you know it's like a
smaller business you don't really like
it's a small business the owner is right
there the guy making you the sandwich is
the guy who owns the shop and says okay
I'll make you a new sandwich I'm the
boss I'll eat the cost you go to a
sandwich shop corporate sandwich shop
and you say I want you made my sandwich
wrong like sir I just make $10 an hour I
have no idea what to do and you can't
get anything done this is I noticed this
when social media appeared because it
was for the first time in my life when I
started using Google uh I was like I
can't contact anyone at Google I don't
know how to get through to someone all
in the '90s and in the ' 80s if you ever
used a product every day you could
always call a number to talk to someone
that would elevate your call to the next
person there's always a way to get
through to that company as far as I
could tell and then social media perod
and they were just overloaded it's
they're too centralized power with so
few people now they don't and then to
accept that allows for what you're
saying now other companies are doing it
easy example you start a business uh I
knew a guy who who uh had a business
online where he sold products one day
his sales evaporated and it was because
Google changed their search algorithm so
it used to be that if you're looking for
product you'd type in the search bar
product search bar product the website
would be in the top five and he worked
really hard to make sure he had the
proper SEO and he was making six figures
Google changes their algorithm he's gone
and there's nothing that was done and
nothing can be done that's like opening
a brick-and-mortar shop and one day you
wake up and your Shop's been moved to
the middle of a field 100 miles away
it's just that's no sales anymore the
problem here not only that but also who
are you going to
call there is no customer service for
any of these companies now with with
Twitter X it's changing because you
subscribe to blue or premium or or
business all of a sudden people are
tweeting at you so we we bought ads I
bought a commercial for Alex Stein's
Prime Time grind two times caffeine
casper.com and it was not it was like
rejected so I tweeted Twitter still has
not approved this ad we're putting
$25,000 behind this Alex Stein
commercial and immediately someone from
X responded saying on it and hit the
button got it going it it has been since
the dawn of the internet age that
Twitter is basically the place you go to
get things done got a problem on YouTube
tweet at them thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
Tim .c for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time